serious stuff to discuss but I really
think that as culture secretary we've
gotta start off with the roughy where
are you watching the match yesterday and
what did you make it the performance by
England well I was watching it in my
kitchen and I thought it was fantastic
oh I'm not gonna comment on the details
of a run I'm a rugby fan but I thought
the fact that England scored so quickly
really put them on top and fantastic
they're going to be in the final of
course we should wish Wales all the best
because they'll be starting their match
very soon and wouldn't be amazing to
have an England Wales final but let's
just see what happens this morning here
would you be supporting them in a Wales
England final well it's quite difficult
being called a Morgan and my maiden name
is a Griffith but I I suspect I'll be
Terry Chaney England on but you know at
the end of the day let's just see who
gets that final very nice navigated now
on to the important stuff shall we sa
because we know of course that Boris
Johnson wants to see a general in action
and his route to getting that early poll
has been blocked so far he's gonna have
another go on Monday but we have heard
the details of this plan by the Lib Dems
and the SNP to potentially back an early
election if the EU grants that extension
will the government be backing the Lib
Dems plan for an election that could
come as early as December the 9th look I
think we need to unpick this a little
bit so firstly and the Prime Minister
doesn't I mean reluctantly has concluded
an election that may be necessary
actually what the Prime Minister and the
government want is to get brexit done
and we have tried all we can to make
sure that can happen by the 31st of
October and of course it's worth bearing
in mind at the moment with No Deal
agreed by Parliament and the EU not
having granted an extension the default
leaving date is still this Thursday so
that should focus minds the second thing
is that actually the Prime Minister has
also said we want to give time to the
House of Commons to Parliament to see if
we can get the withdrawal implementation
bill agreed before we have an election
so actually what is different about the
offer or the stunt I might say by the
SNP and the Lib Dem is
they have obviously they've made it
clear they have no intention of wanting
brexit to be done no intention of
wanting the drawer bill which did get
its second reading approved last week to
be considered by Parliament they're
saying go for an election now it may
well be that an election obviously is
going to happen if the SNP or that if
there's want election they have a chance
to vote for one as quickly as tomorrow
when the government's motion is voted on
and we'll see whether they're in our
lobby or not so you just describes the
move as a stunt just to be really
crystal clear here does that mean that
the government will be voting against
this when it comes to the House of
Commons this week well first thing we
want to see obviously in what context it
comes but as I say there is a very clear
motion tomorrow if the Lib Dems in the
SNP really want there to be an election
then they can vote for our motion
tomorrow that would give Parliament time
to consider withdrawal implementation
bill until November the 6th when a part
when the Parliament have to be dissolved
for a December the 12th election you
know I think that is what we should do
which is give time to MPs to consider
the bill to see if we can get the deal
done but if not and as the Prime
Minister has concluded we do need a new
Parliament and that is why there should
be an election it's your concern then
about this plan by the Lib Dems
understand the SNP that it may not give
mp's the chance to actually vote for the
agreement that's on the table that
they're effectively trying to thwart the
Prime Minister's brexit deal yes I
absolutely I think that we know where
the the Lib Dems and the SNP are if they
get their wish for an election and the
same if the Labour Party which is
extraordinary that an official
opposition whose job is to challenge the
government to elections Jeremy Corbyn
has said 35 times at 2017 he wants
election and now he won't vote for one
if they were to get their way actually
they were to be successful we'd spend
2020 arguing about two referendums
another brexit referendum and another
Scottish independence referendum I
didn't see any public appetite for those
things actually what people do want and
what the government is trying to do is
to get a brexit done we wanted to get it
done by 31st of October but we want to
carry on trying to get that bill
and to be as I say to follow up on the
MPs scrutiny point that they want more
time but if we can't do that then it's
right that there is a deadline and we
have that deadline in the form of an
election on December the 12th you see
this is where I get a little bit
confused because you say you want to try
and get brexit done you say that you
want to try and get this deal through
the House of Commons and it does feel as
if we're perhaps closer to getting a
majority for a brexit agreement than we
ever had been before so why is it that
the Prime Minister is talking about an
election at all well because it has to
be a deadline for these these things I
think that that's so far what we have
seen as the Prime Minister has said is
that Parliament has willed the ends ie
the withdrawal bill being approved the
second medium vote but not the means
which is the timetable motion in order
for a bill to be scrutinized a bill like
this would normally have a timetable
motion attached to it now that's why
he's saying we've got until November the
6th which is the day that Parliament has
to be dissolved for a December the 12th
election which is really the last
practical day before at the end of the
year to hold an election so frankly MPs
I think who want to get the bill through
what to get brexit done and it's very
important and I think for the sake of
the country we've got to bring this
uncertainty to an end you know we've got
a lot of other priorities as a
government and I think the people have
got priorities they want us to be
focusing on so we need to have that
deadline if that means we have to work
all the hours day and night weekend's we
now and November the 6th then I hope
that my par mature colleagues would want
to do this to get that bill through get
brexit done and then to say to the
country right let's have a new
Parliament so we can deliver on the
priorities people have their say we
deliver on the priorities that they most
care about things that the Primus has
talked about their neck chest about
policing about education funding you
know issues in my area about better
broadband mobile connectivity for
example for the whole of the country now
I know that you want to see Parliament
voting in favour of an election tomorrow
when Boris Johnson brings up to the
House of Commons that's a given but what
happens if MP's don't will the
government then effectively just first
drop and pull the legislation well what
we will do is we will keep asking for
the
election and we will find ways to do
that to make it very clear that
particular to say that the Labour Party
you've got the shadow health secretary
coming on later on you will have to
explain why is that the elements well
it's a motion to have the withdrawal
bill to be scrutinized and an election
on December at the 12th because I think
the country does want us to find a way
to move this whole process on it's
important those two things go on but of
course there'll be other parliamentary
business things that have to be done the
government is still focusing on the
priorities that people care about we
will continue to do that but this huge
issue of brexit we have got to find a
way to move it on and that we have
concluded I say reluctantly in the sense
that I don't think an early election or
a winter election is what anybody had
had planned but actually we've got to
find a way to draw a line and to move
this whole process on we've got a deal
on the table and the people who say they
want to avoid a No Deal they're only two
ways to do that one is to get this deal
approved have a deal and the second is
to revoke article 50 and people need to
be very very clear about what it is they
want if they want there to be a deal
they want to avoid a deal we need to get
this deal and this bill through
Parliament now you have course voted to
remain in the referendum are you too
worried and if Boris Johnson wins a
majority at the general election that
you want then he won't have to try and
seek a compromise brexit deal he won't
have to try and pacify remain as like
yourselves he can pursue a much looser
relationship with the EU even
potentially No Deal no that doesn't mean
I don't think that's the Prime
Minister's intention at all he would not
have put such a huge amount of personal
effort and got the whole government
machine to be pulling towards
negotiating this deal with EU a deal by
the way that everybody over the summer
said could not be negotiated withdrawal
agreement cannot be reopened the Prime
Minister achieved that new deal with an
85 days and he did say with EU leaders
well he does that he had given me
assurance is that he wants that he's got
this deal he wants this deal he said
that in the House of Commons last week
he wants this deal to be approved by the
House of Commons and I think that is
likely the right thing to do and
the thing is we can't even get on to
talking about the future relationship
really until we have got this deal this
withdrawal bill approved we know we have
an understanding of the outline of the
future relationship in the political
declaration it will be a free trade
agreement we will be concluding
agreements with other countries around
the world that's the forum but I mean I
think the detail of it we can't get on
to until we've got this first phase of
brexit concluded that's what he's
driving
you know people making people so
frustrated and exhausted that their MPs
cannot do what they have say will the
ends by you know virtue is you've
referendum triggering article 50 but I
can't actually bring themselves to get
this exit phase over the line so we get
on to talking about phase two now we've
been talking a lot about elections an
interview so far just wanna have a
little look at something you said back
in May about Boris Johnson you said
there's no doubt he's popular with a
party membership partly because they
think he's got some kind of magic star
got Stardust that's going to mean that
Corbin is definitely beaten at the next
general election I think that's
hopelessly over optimistic so do you
think that if there is an election it
could deliver a nasty surprise for the
prime minister well nobody should ever
be complacent about election results I
mean actually I think the mood I pick up
on the streets and my constituency here
in Loughborough and the Midlands across
the country is that actually people have
enormous sympathy with all the efforts
that Boris Johnson has gone to to get
the deal and to make brexit happen by
the 31st of October a deadline by the
way imposed on the bias by the EU and
again you know something we have striven
to prepare for whether it's a no deal or
whether it's getting a deal which he has
now done but I don't think any
politician should ever go into an
election thinking we know what the
result is going to going to be we don't
take people for granted but I think
people were realized that there's a very
clear choice in this forthcoming
election do you back no the Prime
Minister the government's efforts to get
this brexit issue resolved move on to
phase 2 or do you back those parties who
are going for more dithering and more
delay and in some cases even just
wanting to cancel the referendum result
completely I just wonder though if the
election will also be framed by the fact
that Boris Johnson has broken
his central pledge which is to get the
UK out of the EU by the 31st of October
do ward I mean why should people trust
what he says in any election campaign
well I'll see people make their minds up
but I would say that people should trust
because they can absolutely see all the
efforts that he has gone to in order to
make sure that can happen this is
Parliament's extension Parliament asked
the EU for an extension which by the way
has not yet been granted to extend to
thirty-first of Germans to Rome a clear
what parliaments well part the Prime
Minister was very clear and if you've
been asking me this interview two weeks
ago you either said is the Prime
Minister going to comply with the law
and he absolutely has done that but he
made it very clear this is Parliament's
extension not entirely clear why
Parliament wanted that extension because
they will otherwise find ourselves back
in the situation again in January but
it's Parliament and then then Prime
Minister made it very clear that he
didn't want there to be an extension and
in fact he wanted to get on with getting
the withdraw bill through the House of
Commons now I just want to end the
interview with a story that's really
been playing on all of our minds a lot
this week at the story about thirty-nine
people who were found dead in the back
of this freezing refrigerated trailer
trying to get to the UK on the hope of a
better life and ending the most tragic
of circumstances now we don't know of
course what drove these individuals in
to make this awful journey but what we
do know of course is that people
trafficking Morton de slavery it's a
very real problem here in the United
Kingdom so what is the government doing
to try and sort this out well as you
know the former prime minister Theresa
May was as both Home Secretary and as
Prime Minister and very much making this
a priority modern day slavery we passed
obviously some of the world leading
legislation on this in the previous
Parliament's we pointed the first
slavery Commissioner human trafficking
commissioner and also making sure that
all of our border forces and everyone
involved is much more aware and I think
we all have a duty to be aware because I
think it's very tempting to think that
something like modern-day saver or human
trafficking isn't happening in the
places where we live but sadly it is and
cracking down on the trade both
obviously cap
people who commit offenses here but also
overseas as well it's very important
this is an awful awful tragedy as you
say we do not know yet the stories of
those involved why they felt this was
their route to a better life but there
are lots that we can do to get those
messages out that actually we do not
want to see anything like this happen
again and I'm you know I know the Home
Secretary pretty to tell her ministers
working with border force
I'll determined to do just that and what
does that mean then does that mean being
more aware when we visit a nail salon
when we pay five pounds to have our car
washed
well I think those things are very aware
I think it's been covered in all of us
to to to make sure that we are aware of
the the risks that people are running
that their lives are living but but more
than that it's about cracking down
obviously on those who engage in this
awful trade all the way through the the
chain both here in the UK but also are
back in the countries where people are
being trafficked from and making sure
and we've got agencies both here in the
UK but also working with agencies abroad
and that obviously will continue always
to crack down on the intentions look
this is a priority going back to the
issue we've just been discussing you
know today this this issue about human
trafficking more than slavery is a big
priority yes of course it's getting
attention in government but how much
more attention could we be giving it or
climate change or any other major issues
if we had not spent three and a half
years arguing about the UK leaving the
EU if we just got on and done it